we preset the buyback price so it's the
price at which you can buy the house
back we said it at the beginning so
every single payment is set in a
contract before we even put the offer
down
you get that contract you review it
everything is presets if you don't feel
comfortable with it there's
there's no moving forward what do you
said on the 150 house where would you
preset it at 175
so probably for our folks just easier to
stick with if it's a hundred thousand
dollar house generally we
appreciate about three percent a year so
you can look at it it would be about a
hundred and ten thousand dollars
after three years so that's what i don't
know that's so small back at the halfway
point for 105
000. so you build that into the model
that it's going to appreciate a little
bit
so they get the outside if it
appreciates more
but that's actually what's been
happening in the country so let's get
into modern day
you put people into houses in 2019 in
atlanta and in dallas and they have
correct me if i'm wrong gone up at least
50 percent they have a call option
that's in the money for them yes
yes which in plain english for people
who don't understand means what
it means that the house is now worth
more than what they have the right to
buy
back at so theoretically even you know
if they don't want the house
that hundred thousand dollar house is
now worth 150 000
they have a right to buy it at 110 000
they should buy it they can sell it the
next day and make a 40 000
spread that is their right and that's
what we want now truthfully though
jason like our customers are not
thinking about an arbitrage game here
that is not how it works and no one
thinks about their home in that way i
mean
you're at your house now also i assume
your house has now become your your
children's source of school during cobit
your office right it's like family
center
and so the way that you're thinking
about it is i want to make a sound
financial decision and i want a place to
raise my family and feel safe
right and so our customers are not using
divvy as a way to hedge the market
not yet not yet but i mean if you do
your job
if you do your job and you taught them
how to be an owner
correct me if i'm wrong they're going to
say hey wait i'm an owner
i have 40 000 in profits here
i could you know move an hour outside of
hotlanta
to the next hot place you know somewhere
outside of nashville
for 100k and i could do it again as i
hope they will
that is it that is the dream we are
trying to create well that is the point
of this
but all you get is the the landlord's
spread is there some other secret to
this business that i'm missing well
that's our core business and so the
landlord spread when you get make that
every month consistently for
three years is the average term of our
lease right that's a nice annuity of
cash right it's cash that comes in and
when someone's in the house and they're
fairly stable in that house
there doesn't tend to have to be a ton
of work that needs to go into it once
you have
a tenant who's happy any maintenance
stuff might come up but generally we
know that's that's super seasonal so acs
are going to go out
right around this time of year where
they're starting to use them again right
and we know that heaters are going to go
out
probably in the fall right and so we
know these timings but outside of that
it tends to be very little work and so
you're sitting on an annuity a cash flow
stream
which is how we make the majority of our
profit now that's our core business
as you can imagine we're constantly
thinking about how we could expand
most of our expansion into new services
is actually not for the profit i
actually want to be very transparent
about that
it's actually because we just want a
better customer experience so for
example today a customer comes jason you
go to our website you apply and we say
jason
you're approved for a 300 350 000 house
in dallas
go out shopping with your realtor you go
adina i don't have a realtor
who should i go out shopping with
historically we'd introduce you to a
keller williams agent or century 21
or compass or someone else right one of
our just someone in our network that
didn't work for divvy
you guys go out shopping and you say you
know what happens when i actually want
to buy back the house what price do i
pay
and that agent's like i have no clue
we have to call divvy right and that
creates a pretty friction-filled
customer experience for you and so our
goal is we're going to actually start to
do things like build out a divi
brokerage now the goal the brokerage
obviously we get
a commission right and financially
there's a benefit to that
however the real goal of his goal of it
is that it creates a more seamless
customer experience helps drive up
conversion
so the largest single family landlord
in america is a company called
invitation homes uh they own 80
000 homes their 20 billion dollar
enterprise value company
so the the industry i know you're
thinking this is the margin you make but
when you sit on a series of cash flows
across
what's even tens of thousands of homes
it ends up being a pretty profitable and
large business and i take it without
giving
that blackstone owned entity a hard time
but
blackstone also owns the uh you know sea
world
let's just say these folks are not doing
it for charity or the
you know they might not have as charming
of a origin story as you do
they're in it for the money yes period
so are they let's leave them out so you
don't have to badmouth the competitor
but is that category of
folks um more sharky in the sense that
they're going to be more cutthroat about
the cost of the rent et cetera so i'd
say there's a couple of things
um one most of those competitors have
actually bought portfolios of homes
and so they bought these massive amounts
of foreclosure homes during the crisis
and as you can imagine foreclosure homes
that are sitting there without someone
living in them
can get run down more quickly than
someone that has an actual
tenant so i'd say quality of the
portfolio is a bit lower
a lot lower than what it is for divi
where our customers go out they find
the best home the home that they want to
raise their kids in so overall the
quality of our portfolio is better which
means that our tenants are getting a
better experience they're getting a
better home than they are
the best owners well not only that
they're picking out the home you're
picking out what home you want you're
not
and and for sale inventory is always
better than rental inventory rental
inventories just run down right
yes um and so i think that the customers
get a better experience because they get
to pick out the home
the home quality is better um we try our
best to be
you know really forward thinking around
things like you don't have to worry
about paying rent every month it gets
automatically
pulled if you opt in from your bank
account you get an email that notifies
you in a text that notifies you how your
rent has been paid i mean i even think
about my own experience in san francisco
before i was a homeowner
i used to have to log onto my bank
account and wire every month
to my landlord right we want to take
away all the friction and just make this
a really beautiful experience
that helps guide people through the path
into home ownership
makes total sense except
your competitors are getting all that
appreciation of the homes and you're not
they are we're sharing in that
appreciation with our our tenants who
are in the house for sure
we get the three percent so i guess we
do get the three percent
yeah so and i guess i'm trying to think
historically what is historically the
last 20 years
look like is it three percent in the
markets you're in no they've appreciated
much more in fact right now
i think average price home prices are up
call it 15 to 20
year-over-year right now and so we're
giving a ton of that upside to the
customer but that's okay
right our view is that if you can create
a portfolio
where you treat the customer right you
give them access to this our customers
end up turning over
at a lower frequency we end up cashing
better they take better care of the home
with lower maintenance and
ultimately our profit margin from what
we can get from rental income
ends up going up because we have to
spend less on turns
uh so basically if someone if a customer
leaves the house basically filling that
house with another rental tenant
and we have to spend less on maintenance
and so far that
bet has held very true we make a better
profit margin than any single family
read out there because this bet is
actually holding true
in today's startup landscape committing
to security and compliance is vital for
growth
and proof of your company's security
posture has never been more
important as you scale you might start
to receive
more sock two requests from customers
and that's where drata comes
in trada is an advanced automation
platform used by some of the world's
leading chief
information security officers or csos
strata will help you successfully meet
requirements support enterprise deal
flow and continually track
compliance drata also helps customers
easily prepare for
and clear sock 2 and other audits so you
can go from zero to audit ready in a
matter of weeks
need more take it from philip martin
chief security officer at coinbase and
here's his quote
it became clear to me right away that
drata is an engineering powerhouse
the solution they've developed is well
ahead of other market players
their approach to deep native
integrations provides users with the
most advanced automation
available so check out drata's five-star
reviews on g2
and see why companies like clear close
smart recruiter and
the good face project work withdrawda
for their compliance needs twist
listeners can get
15 off and waived implementation fees at
drata.com twist d-r-a-t-a dot com slash
twist
you